hey constantin do you like saving money
you know i do
well i've just found this great thing
called pouch
i know all about it it's a brilliant
free browser extension that
automatically searches for
and applies discounts when you're
shopping online saving you both time
and money well why don't we get you a
discount on a brand new jacket that
makes you look
as if you don't work in a beefeater
here's us browsing for a fancy new
blazer for constantine
and at checkout pouch automatically
popped up
found the best discount code saving us
over 20
pouch works on over 3 000 uk
sites that's more than any other browser
extension that offers a similar service
so you'll be guaranteed to find a
bargain and it's free to download using
the link
in the description that's another
bargain as well not as much
as never seeing you in that jacket again
actually that's a great thing about
pouch
whatever it is that you're looking for
you'll find the cheapest possible price
with them
click the link in the description and
download pouch for free
pouch only takes a couple of clicks to
install
and don't forget to pin it to your
browser should we look for some personal
training sessions for you then
no thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people we're delighted to say that our
brilliant and returning guest today is
the editor-in-chief of aero magazine
and the co-author of cynical theories
with another one of our former guest
james lindsey
helen pluck rose welcome back to
trigonometry oh it's good to be here
nice to see you again
it's great to to have you back on the
show uh we talked to you a couple of
years ago
uh about some of the stuff that uh you
cover in cynical theories but
uh kind of a lot has happened since then
where do you think
society's moved and the some of the
things that you've been talking about
have moved over the last couple of years
i think i think even since i finished
writing cynical theories we've just seen
such a massive
escalation of um these ideas which
people have been criticizing for about
10 years now but for about
five um it's people have been really
becoming aware
of the whole idea of um white
supremacy whiteness white fragility and
toxic masculinity cisnormativity all of
these um
kind of orthodoxies but i think in the
last
year particularly it really has
intensified and
developed a great amount of power that
is impacting
um generally everybody you don't have to
be
at a university or part of an activist
group to be hit by this stuff now
and why do you think it's intensified
helen
i think there's so many reasons um
so many things have happened and i think
there's a lot of sort of sociological
um arguments for why this has taken off
right now but i
i i'm mostly focused on how it's
developed
within scholarship and activism of
course the the
the trigger for the immediate escalation
was the death of george floyd
and this i think it's not a coincidence
that this happened at a time when there
was a pandemic and
people wanted something to fight and
they can't we can't really fight the
virus so we've
but i think it was bubbling below the
surface before this so we saw
it sort of come up in places like
evergreen college
and in the knitting um
community and the young adult books
community so
it's like this critical social justice
stuff i think you know most people call
it wokism
which is actually a really good word
because it it describes the belief that
you can see these systems of power and
privilege that most people can't
and it's been bubbling up and it's been
erupting in various places
and what we're seeing now particularly
in the us
is a mass eruption i um
i would i would go so far and i'm you
know i'm
generally very much inclined to british
understatement
but i would go so far as to call this an
a genuine attempted cultural
um a revolution and i think it needs
pushing back
i i agree with you on that what you know
remember remember last time we talked
with you one of the things that i was
most interested in is
obviously these ideas that that can be
broadly described as woke
come from a certain subsection of the
left you yourself are on the left i
are you even more frustrated than you
were a couple of years ago about
how difficult it's become to challenge
some of the stuff while
retaining your left identification
because people
the moment you say anything about this
stuff people do try to push you out and
claim that you're some right-wing bigger
et cetera
i i'm you know that there are a whole
sort of swathes of people who won't
accept that i'm on the left because
i'm neither a socialist nor
a um social justice activist but i am
an economic leftist with um socialist
sympathies and i'm i'm a left-leaning
liberal so i'm just used to people now
telling me that i'm a
fascist or a nazi or sometimes because
i also um tend to annoy the
right and particularly um recently when
i um wrote a piece um urging
um americans to to vote biden um
i also get told that i am a um a comey
and an sjw
so i'm you know i'm just it's a great
combination
but look for anyone who's listening to
this who's thinking you know what
i've always thought of myself as someone
who's on the left
i've always thought of myself as someone
who's liberal i've always
wanted to look out for the underdogs in
life i've always
you know these are my views but equally
all this woke stuff
doesn't make sense to me what is a
credible
left-wing position that is not woke
that you support why are you elected
just articulate that for people for the
positive case for being on the left
okay so liberalism this is two two
aspects
and they're they're not exactly the same
thing so liberalism
is the desire for equal opportunity for
individuality for universality for
freedom of speech and belief
so there can be liberals on the right
left and center
a liberal lefty um like me is somebody
who
um believes in these vital freedoms in
these end of this individuality and not
judging people by their race gender or
sexuality and ensuring that society
doesn't do so either but has genuinely
leftist policies like i i would like to
tax rich people quite a lot more in
order to better fund the nhs
and have less fewer children relying on
food banks and generally have a better
welfare
system and affordable housing for um
for poorer people uh many of whom are
not white so this should be
um somewhere where we can sort of share
interest with
uh both marxists and the um critical
social justice activists but they
um they tend to be purists the latter's
the marxists will talk to you
they'll um but not the critical social
justice
people and why is that why do they not
engage in debates because surely the way
you persuade somebody
to your point of view is by talking to
them right yeah
that's the liberal marketplace of ideas
but what we've seen
coming from the social justice left is
the
idea of dominant discourses which of
course comes
from post-modernism in the first place
um
well it's got a longer history than that
but let's go with michelle foucault
as a good grounding point here this idea
that certain discourses in society
certain ways of talking about things
become powerful because they get
legitimated by powerful
structures in society and then we all
speak
into them without even realizing we're
doing it and these power structures can
be called things like white supremacy
patriarchy cisnormativity you know the
the belief that
um people are generally the same gender
as their genitals indicate their sexes
so that's when you believe in dominant
discourses
and marginalized discourses you can't
believe that a marketplace of ideas will
work
all that will happen is that the
dominant discourses get an
and people just accept that as the truth
and the marginalized people are still
not hurt so this is why we hear that
they are silenced they are erased
and because there's this idea that if
anybody
um is speaking into a dominant discourse
it doesn't matter if it's
the president of the united states or
someone with three followers on twitter
they're likely to be lept upon and um
told precisely how they are being
problematic
but isn't helen isn't one of the things
that is so
persuasive about this it's like the best
lies
the best lies always have a kernel of
truth
isn't that particularly relevant when we
look at critical race theory because
racism does exist people are repressed
you know
women that do have it harder when it
comes to things like
you know like worrying about their own
physical safety etc etc
okay well i disagree with the last one
you're much more likely to become a
victim of violence than
i am but uh he keeps saying it he nearly
got mugged three weeks ago and he keeps
saying that same thing no i'm a real man
i can defend myself
yeah but what actually happened was the
guy tried to grab his wallet
out of his hand twisted his wrist and he
was complaining for three weeks
six weeks but i kept my wallet but yeah
i mean
the kernel of truth is is racism exists
and homophobia exists um
nasty sort of bigotry against trans
people
exist which needs to be separated from a
belief
about sex being a biological category
which people should be able to hold
so yes nobody i think is denying
that um these prejudices still exist the
problem
is what we disagree about is how we go
around fixing them
so between the 60s and the 80s that was
when we saw
a real leap forwards in um civil rights
racial equality lgbt equality
gender equality but a whole load of
legislation was passed
and a big sort of cultural revolution
and it was a liberal one
so this all happened before the critical
social justice
ideas really started taking off which
which
happened around 1989
when these ideas really started
branching so this is the liberal thing
this is
when you say um i am a human being
just like you and i don't have the same
rights the same
opportunities that you do this isn't
fair
we we need universal human rights and
society
says um yes actually you do women should
be paid as much as men
and we shouldn't prosecute gay men for
having consensual sex with each other
you know this this is uh the liberal
approach
and there's it's worked it works really
well and it can continue working
but for the social justice activists
this isn't enough um
we after the sort of legislation had
changed
what remained was changing attitudes so
racism hasn't gone away
um sexism hasn't gone away there are
still people with horrible ideas out
there
the liberals will say we can need to
continue arguing with these people
we need to continue discrediting these
ideas
and we can see how much we have if
you're
you know i'm 46 i see a
dramatic difference in the public
acceptability
of using a racist slur now than i did
when in my 20s i think we have got
we've seen significant improvement in my
lifetime
so this is the the liberal approach we
just frown
generally upon people evaluating other
people by
their immutable characteristics it's
both stupid and unethical
so but that isn't how the critical
social justice
um works that wants to control how you
speak it wants to insist that you must
be racist
and you must be sexist you must have all
of these assumptions you do
you're not an individual with the agency
and the ability
to evaluate ideas and reject and accept
them that's a naive simplistic liberal
belief
and how do you i mean i mean the
question i suppose that comes out of
all of what you're saying is if the
marketplace of ideas doesn't work
for conversations with people who have
this critical
uh just social justice mindset
how do you how do we have a society
and and how do we manage that if
conversation
isn't the answer because it seems to me
that that from their perspective
they are the bringers of truth and
everyone else must accept that truth
so how do we deal with that as a society
i i think we need to put
critical social justice in the right
category at the moment it's in the wrong
category
of just being a general ethical approach
to um anti-discrimination which
um we should um sort of
make into our laws into employment
policies but it
doesn't belong in this category of
training
like um you know data protection and
health and safety
it's much more of a belief system you
have to believe
in social constructivism you have to
believe in these invisible systems of
power and privilege
and the way they work and the way that
they progress in language
it's a specific belief system so we need
to apply
the rules of secularism to it so just as
a christian
or a muslim or a hindu may believe that
they are absolutely right
um and that it's very very important
that everybody else in society accepts
that they are right
we have these rules in places where we
say um okay
we protect your right to believe that to
say that
and to live your life by it but not to
impose it on anyone else
and that is what we need to do with
critical social justice ideas we need to
put them in that box
i mean helen you say that but it's all
very well for us to sit around here and
say that you know we've got a successful
podcast youtube
show you're a successful author but
there are a lot of people out there that
if they stood up in their diversity
training
or whatever else it may be in their
workplace they will very likely either
be fired or have their careers stunted
as a result
yes that is the problem and i'm hearing
from thousands of them
and i hear and so did almost everybody
in this sphere
and that is why we have set up what
began as a
discord server to triage the worst cases
about seven months ago
is now forming an organization
counterweight
and i think we are filling the gap that
um is needed because while we see a lot
of cases when a celebrity
gets cancelled or if an academic um
is fired or has their paper retracted we
don't see
a lot of how this is affecting the
average person
in their daily life now i hear from
these people and i will you know i heard
from the supermarket
um assistant who um
accidentally called a trans woman sir
and
um then when um the customer became
quite irate and said do i look like a
man to you
um she instinctively said yes not
meaning to be rude but then
got all flustered and and then there was
disciplinary action and then she didn't
know what to do
and she didn't even know anything about
the trans movement so
you know we're getting there there is a
lot of reasons why people
um who are not don't have power don't
have a platform
don't have um an academic background
which enables them
to feel confident in making arguments in
writing and defending them
and it's a lot harder for them to push
back at this so
we have set up counterweight which works
as a caseworker system
someone will come to us they will say my
workplace is setting up this policy
i need to respond to it what should i do
then we can connect them with other
people in their sphere
we can connect them with legal advice if
necessary we can connect them with me
if we want to go through um theoretical
assumptions
and what they want to challenge with
that we can sort of produce
provide them with a personalized package
and we've had a lot
of success people a lot of our members
have got themselves onto diversity
equity and inclusion boards
where they've argued for a broader range
of
ideas on how to oppose discrimination
and we're producing accessible
educational
um resources so there's a lot of short
articles but there's also a youtube
channel counterweight media
which um looks at the problems with um
unconscious bias training with lived
experience at work and
a lot of the other um you know the
things that people really see that
that just hit them in the face right now
that we i i think the way to push back
at this it's got to be knowledge
knowledgeable and it's got to be
principled and these ideas
aren't that difficult to understand so
our
aim is to help people to understand them
and then to push back at them
in a way that they feel safe to do so
uh armed with knowledge and with
principle
you know not you don't have to throw
yourself on the grenade it's okay to
want to be able to make a living
well it's a very good point and of
course we have seen
this idea of council culture to just
absolutely take off in the last couple
of years and
uh dozens of people being hounded out of
jobs handed out of
book deals etc do you think obviously
you've created counterweight and
you know the free speech union is doing
its part
do you think the answer to a lot of this
is going to be
through the creation of institutions
like the ones
we've just talked about because
individuals are not going to be able to
resist
this on their own yeah i i think this is
what
we need we need people who are doing
this sort of big
loud in your face see this problem
approach and then we need people who are
taking a more behind-the-scenes approach
um like us where you know we're just
helping people address a problem before
it gets to the point of disciplinary
action or needing the free speech union
so someone comes to us and they're a
brit
we we advise them to join the free
speech union as one of the first steps
anyway
but we aim to help them resolve the
problem
before it gets the stage of needing um
that kind of intervention from anyone
else and we've had a lot of success with
that
it's particularly um helpful that a lot
of
our members aren't white so if they get
themselves
onto diversity equity and inclusion
boards and they argue against critical
race theory ideas and they argue for
humanist ones
or perhaps um they come from
a background which has a different
culture that
that has doesn't really value these sort
of post-modern critical
social justice ideas it's quite
difficult for
people from um one of the abrahamic
faiths for example
to accept this idea that they don't have
free will which
um their faith tells them they do and
that they
they they can't choose um
good ideas over bad ones so
there's a lot of ways to go at this
which
are relatively safe and are aimed mostly
at
viewpoint diversity and freedom of
belief rather than
critical race theory is bad and needs to
be banned
it's a very very good strategy helen you
know we see and we talk to people
who have been cancelled all the time why
is it
that the people on the other side of
this particular argument don't believe
canceled culture exists
uh the argument generally from the other
side
is that um what we are calling cancel
culture
is actually powerful powerless people um
rising up um on mass to
fight back against bad ideas that are
harming them
so we get the idea that i mean we're not
going to cancel
jk rowling she's um she's too
influential and too few people
um care about um
where the gender identity is real as
much as they care about you know harry
potter
but the she has been a major target of
this
because she isn't such an influential
figure
and the idea is that by speaking into
this discourse which says that woman is
a biological category
that has certain experiences that come
along with it
she is doing incredible harm to trans
people
so we saw the reaction to that from a
lot of the actors or the harry potter
films
was to repeat the mantra trans women are
women trans women are women
trans women and women and then we can
see how much this is about discourse
and the idea that there's this dominant
transphobic discourse that needs to be
responded to by this
pro transactivism discourse
in order to liberate
and protect trans people most of whom
by the way are not um trans activists of
the
social justice kind and don't read queer
theory and um are not
author authoritarian lunatics
hey constantine yeah are you tired of
all those typical meditation techniques
that leave your masculinity
wanting more yeah i've tried them all
mindfulness zen
transcendental and i still feel like my
life is lacking
well maybe you should try marty's minute
meditations mean it meditation is that
pun
yes it is that's right with the comedic
and mystical
marty's minute meditations podcast we
can all discover how to save
our sacred masculine from our toxic
modern
selves i swear to god i prefer
advertising b days
the podcast is available from wherever
you get your podcast
and you can also visit the website
www.marty'sminutemeditations.com
that's marty's minute meditations.com
might as well get a b there while you're
there okay look
jk rowling obviously very wealthy you'd
imagine influential well connected etc
but we've had you know people like nick
buckley on our show for example who
who who to his credit but also to his
downfall
during the whole blm thing in may uh
of last year he he went on their website
and read
their policies and then when well maybe
this isn't such a good idea given what
they're advocating
and he was removed from his own charity
yeah this is just a guy who was helping
underprivileged kids in inner cities he
wasn't
selling millions of books and you know
it's swanning around
in in frogs right so what about someone
like him
what would be the argument surely he got
canceled didn't he
yeah i i whether or not we call it
cancels or
whatever we call it he got unjustly um
penalized there was an attempt to
destroy his reputation to destroy his
livelihood
because he expressed an idea that some
people didn't like now that that's
a serious problem in a liberal
what would they say to that i i think
they
they would say that um this was
um a pushback against a powerful white
supremacist discourse
that is warranted because um it's
harming
uh people of color particularly black
people so
the idea that um you know you
you can push back this idea of
repressive
um tolerance that that you just don't
allow the kind of speech that um
they believe hurts people if you believe
reality is constructed by
the way we speak about things then
language does become violence
it then becomes justifiable to respond
to it by
silencing people by completely
destroying their reputation from
removing them
from society or even from being violent
to them
and why is it you know i i just every
time you articulate it so beautifully
and i and you know i find myself really
understanding it even though it's to me
palpable nonsense
but why these people never seem to talk
about class
they talk about white people as being a
monolith without accepting that
we have real problems in this country
and america
with white people who are in poverty but
immediately
the fact that you're white means you're
privileged even if you can't afford to
put food on your table
yeah i really don't understand that
that's um
that this is where a kind of motton
bailey move happens
so if you were to say this to a critical
racist or an intersectional feminist
they would say class does matter we're
not saying that
white people are privileged in every
area we're only saying that they
don't suffer discrimination on the
grounds of their race
but in reality what actually happens if
you try to bring up um any kind of class
issue
is that it's then brought back to race
you wouldn't um
hear somebody say to say a black
activist
um yes we understand that um you have
that you're you know you're not um
advantaged in every way but one of your
problems is not that you
are poor we there isn't a reversal of
that
we've seen two main issues come and take
top priority and that is race and
um trans identity at the moment so
a trying there's there's often a lip
service to
class issues but if you were to raise
the issue
of and say the number of poor homeless
um white men uh on the streets then they
it would be brought up that
that is a neglect of poor homeless black
men
and that they have um an additional um
burden uh as well as being um homeless
and poor
so it they'll find a way to bring
things back there isn't the the
universalism that the humanism that
that liberals would would like to see in
there
helen i wanted to ask you something a
little bit earlier you were talking
about how in your organization you have
a lot of people from ethnic
minority backgrounds etc as a liberal
do you not resent having to say that
because i resent that i resent the fact
that
i have to say on our show and francis
has to say well actually my mom is from
venezuela and i have to say
i am an immigrant and i am from this but
like
surely can we just go back to a place
where we're like
this is my idea and you go that's a [ __ ]
idea constantine and it's got nothing to
do with your race
can we just you'll always be an
immigrant
do you not find that like we've already
bought into their way of thinking by
even having to mention all this stuff
yeah that's because i mean the idea of
post-modernism is that it is post
um this liberal um epoch
so it is now understood that this idea
that um you and i could discuss things
um on the level of ideas without power
dynamics
and playing into things without um you
know me
um not being an immigrant you not being
a woman
um it gives us certain kinds of
privileges that um
that need to be addressed they just want
to focus on these kinds
of privileges and that is where
i i think yeah we do need to avoid
following people down this rabbit hole
as far as we can
but we need to understand the rabbit
hole so quite often
um it's as simple as saying i don't
share the premises
that your statement just that your
statement relies on
if someone says to you how do you as a
man
uh have the right to address the um
issues of gender-based violence or
something
um you can say i don't uh share your
premise that i have to have a certain
identity to address a certain issue
well i could just say i'm russian in
which case it all goes out of the window
but helen you know what let's just say
that for the sake of argument we accept
this fact that
you know women trans people are more
oppressed than men
people from certain ethnic backgrounds
have more of a right to speak about
racial issues than white people
let's let's accept all that what happens
then when you get uh someone who's like
trevor phillips the former
chairman of the equalities commission
who comes out against this work stuff
or other prominent black people or women
or trans people who don't buy into it
and they get attacked now how do you
square that circle how do you explain
that if we buy into this thing that
oppressed people of the ones that should
be allowed to speak you then get an
oppressed person who doesn't buy into
this crap
they then get how does that work how
does that make any sense
that's that that's where the dominant
discourses come in again
so when they had uh the marxist ideas it
it was quite clear that there was a
group of people that were oppressing
another group of people
when you get fucodian ideas you've got
powerful discourses
so it doesn't really matter um
what your identity is although it's
about identity politics although they'll
say
only black people get to speak on this
they mean black people who
um agree with social uh justice
discourse so
if you are a black person who doesn't if
you
are say a black conservative
then you have bought into a white
supremacist discourse
and um you are at best brainwashed
at worst you are a traitor to your own
people by trying to secure advantage to
yourself by pandering to the white
supremacist
society so we get a lot of people
um particularly south asian women from
hindu and sikh backgrounds
um make up uh our membership who
really and that they tend to be
professional
uh women successful women and they tend
to get a bit annoyed
about having to speak about being women
of color rather than
speaking about being architects or
archaeologists or
you know whatever it is they're actually
doing
so there's one of our first projects
we're hoping we're calling out at our
black intellectual diversity project
and we're getting a load of black
intellectuals to write a chapter
on their favorite black intellectual who
deals with issues of race and racism
and why they think their approach is
particularly valuable so we want
everyone from ibrahmax kennedy to thomas
cell
and we want them we're going to have
marxist libertarians pan-africanists
and separatists liberals humanists
everybody
um in this one book and we're going to
put those views out there so this book
i'm hoping it'll be a manifestation of
the marketplace of ideas and my imagined
audience is a young person who wants to
make up her own mind
how she thinks about politics and how
she thinks about
racism and she can read these ideas from
people
you know as varied as shelby steele who
takes a very sort of individual
responsibility approach
to people like ibra max candy who um
any any inequality any disparity can
only be caused by
um racism and it's actually um
anti-racist to discriminate if
if that's the case and i get all these
ideas together
the problem we're finding is we can't at
the moment get critical race theorists
or intersectional feminists to write
anything in a book alongside
libertarians conservatives or marxists
so
it's um and we may end up with a
a chapter of that book called the
chapter that should have been
in which i will set forward a lot of the
arguments of some of the most
prominent um critical race
and then they will accuse you of
misrepresenting it it's the same we have
the same problem on the show whenever we
invite people like that on they won't
come on
this is the thing i i can't prove any
anything i i know
i was invited to join a panel on
intersectional feminism and then all the
intersectional feminists
dropped out coincidentally and i was
invited to join a panel on whether we
need to decolonize the university and
the
people on the yes side dropped out
mostly i i don't know i got you know
they um
don't necessarily say i won't be on a
platform
with a critic of my ideas but sometimes
they do
i i got um publicly disinvited from the
decolonized stem
symposium even though i had been up
front with my own name
and i'd put forward the my own argument
that i was going to make which is that
saying that stem
is white western and male is actually
sexist and racist um but i i said it in
the language so
um you know post-colonial language so
they probably didn't understand it
but after googling me i was um
informed that i was a danger to the
other attendees
and that um their safety had to be
um considered paramount because it you
know it's just so hazardous
if you go in there and suggest that
people who aren't white
do science as well um
helen look we're talking about you know
the
the intellectual aspect of it but let me
ask you a pretty brutal question which
is
isn't this just a way to exploit white
guilt
i i think we have to assume
good will i think there's always going
to be opportunists
um in any kind of movement i think
shelby steele is the um person who has
addressed white guilt and
um sort of how that can be exploited at
most length
but whenever we're dealing with any
individualness there's really strong
evidence that they
are um seeking power um for themselves
in an opportunistic way i think we have
to assume that they genuinely believe
what they say they believe and we have
to try and address
um those ideas and and try to find some
common ground and move them from them
a bit if we can you know you talk about
finding common ground but isn't that
practically impossible if people don't
want to engage in a debate or a
conversation
it's there are many people with whom it
is literally
um impossible because they just won't
talk to you at all
um so if you know someone like um robin
d'angelo just um
always refuses to um debate with any
um black um intellectual or anyone
who disagrees with her uh so yes then
you can't do anything
yeah and you can't um if
if somebody really is sucked deeply into
an ideology
it may be almost impossible to get them
out it you know
we've seen people join cults and before
and and the difficulty that
um they have they have to realize a
problem for themselves usually
but i think there's a very small number
of people who really are committed um
ideologues in this way so i i took the
tribes test it's for america so i
shouldn't have done really but
um and that shows that um only 12
of people um are progressive activists
who um could have these ideas and it
included me
among that 12 percent really so
i think there really is a small number
of people
who um hold these ideas really strongly
and then there's a large number of
people who
are condoning and enabling them because
they don't understand um that this isn't
a liberal and friendly thing or because
they're afraid of being considered
um racist or sexist or you know
who wants to seem to stand against
social justice
but quite often i'll get a an email from
someone
saying i think i'm the only person in my
institution
who has uh has any concerns about this
and i'll be able to say no actually
you're not
would you like me to introduce you and
and that's
another major thing that that we're
doing we're introducing people to each
other and emboldening them they're
finding people in their own profession
and even in their own organization
um who they didn't realize had the same
worries that they did and we can kind of
uh reach a kind of tipping point helen
the one thing that i always find really
sad about this
obviously people losing their jobs
having their careers blighted is sad
the thing that i find really tragic is
when this tears apart families
we get emails from people saying my
daughter no longer speaks to me
my son and daughter have fallen apart as
a result of this
is that particularly common or is does
that tend to be in the minority
i don't i when i've if you read the
reality
lodge for example i i've just finished
natives by akala
and we're looking at people who are
mixed race but
who identify as black because of
how um people are do tend to be
racialized
um and yeah there's uh there's an
alienation
that can occur if you get too deeply
into these
ideas i've um one a case study that
we're
about to sort of anonymously talk about
as well
is about a parent of an eight-year-old
boy
who has been taught about white
supremacy and anti-blackness
and has become very upset and he isn't
sure how to think
now about his parents you know his
mother is white his father is black
hat what um is he supposed to think
about this is is he half
bad this is the really kind of
upsetting thing and i know how easy it
is to get sucked into this when i was
researching for one of our papers i read
about six of these books in two days
and then i decided to try and unwind by
watching csi or something
and there was a scene in which a mixed
race student graduated and she came out
and she hugged her parents and i thought
oh look how lovely she she loves her
mother even though she's white
i think what what has happened to my
brain
and yeah it's really horrible
uh helen and i think it's so exciting
that with counterweight you're giving
people
a way to not get cancelled and to
to to to be able to express themselves
and to think about the stuff honestly
with integrity and i think that would be
a really important part of the process
of pushing back
uh we hope that with what we do on this
show giving voices to different people
we're giving people at least an
opportunity
as you say to know that they're not the
only ones that is such
a huge chunk of the feedback that we get
as well
do you think that
although all those things are very good
there's going to have to be some
legislative
changes in the future because of how
deeply embedded these
ideas are now within the legal framework
i mean
a lot of people are now taking a
critical look at the equalities act of
2010 in the uk
do you think there is some legislative
work to do on this as well
i do i mean i am not i'm not qualified
to speak
um on law very well that we have been
talking to lawyers about it
and what seems like the the
the thing to do is to take the part of
the equality act which speaks
of um philosophical beliefs as a
protected characteristic
and make and define that much more
clearly as
viewpoint diversity so we have a
situation
where a christian employer could not
force
a muslim employee to be trained to
believe that jesus is the son of god
we also need to have a the right for
people to opt out
of um being trained um to detoxify their
masculinity or
um you know their to overcome their
whiteness and their white fragility
people have to be able to say
i don't believe what you believe and i
don't have to
and helen why is it that certain
industries seem more prone to this than
others i mean
it looks at this point that most of them
are toppling like dominoes
but the first ones to forward the arts
and
those types of industries i i think
obviously this is coming from the
the humanities there's a departure
from sort of
empiricism and rationalism and
liberalism
in the humanities anyway because it's a
largely
um about thought experiments about um
about human emotion and experience so
there's it's going to be we're going to
find more of this kind of theory
arising in um cultural studies than we
are in physics
so that's not really
surprising but i don't but we we see the
effects that it has
um on the sciences and um
sort of indirectly and even some
scientists
um i've just written a response to to
one of them
who thinks our fat studies paper should
be reinstated we agree it should so
um uh where he argues that um
you know that fat studies um really
isn't such a terrible thing and people
should be allowed to
to argue for it and i think yes they
should but it still is actually
um not it is very it's radically
anti-scientific
and so i'm going i'm going to point out
that it's both silly and dangerous
it's an interesting point i mean if you
think about it we've had so much talk
about the need for censoring people who
are skeptical about
lockdown or the efficacy of vaccines or
whatever else
but for the most part until this point
at least you've been able to tell people
to
to be overweight which is terrible for
them with with no censorship whatsoever
it's it's it's an area that needs to be
sort of looked at
isn't it yeah i mean this is where we
need again
some nuance which just doesn't come with
um the sort of really simplistic black
and white social justice approach
there's there's always a kernel of truth
in there there is
um evidence that um heavily overweight
people are less likely
to be to get be offered jobs which
their weight is irrelevant too so and
there's evidence that
um they're less likely to visit their
doctor with any other kind of problem
because they know the doctor will just
tell them to lose weight
so you know there are problems there
there's a need for advocacy but it can't
be
anti-scientific that needs to accept
that um obesity is a genuine
um problem that it is a health
um condition that needs treating
and that it isn't a reason to
be unkind to or discriminate against
obese people
it shouldn't it's not really that
complicated but um
social justice makes it so
and helen what is the end game because
it has to be an endgame
to what these people want what do they
actually want
i think and is it attainable is the
second part to that question i would add
i unlike with um something like marxism
where there's a clear end goal
of um the proletariat owning the means
of production that isn't
what um we're seeing with social justice
people are feeling as though they have
awoken
to a reality that they didn't realize
was there
and they're still feeling at the
beginning stages where we're picking
apart these dominant discourses
that make us believe that men are
stronger than women
or that people who have a penis is are a
man
or that racism um
doesn't underlies everything we have to
there's it still feels very much like
it's at a beginning stage so
the the project is finding it
so one of the tenets of anti-racism
and formed by a group which includes
robin d'angelo
states the the question is not did
racism take place
but how did racism manifest in this
situation
so that's what people are looking for
we're looking for how
racism um manifests and once you find a
way to say that it has
then you've you've got it right and
you've you've managed to unpick and and
show an aspect of the white supremacist
system and so the ant the end game
is to continue doing this dismantling
speech
revealing um structures of power that
exist within
um attitudes biases um unconscious bias
microaggressions etc
and make it all visible then once
everything is out then there's a hope
that we can re-think
everything in ways that aren't racist
sexist and and homophobic but
of course we're starting from the
presumption that
any encounter is going to be racist or
sexist so
it's um confirmation bias at best
but helen doesn't this make you a very
angry person so for instance
if i spent every single minute of every
day walking around
looking for ways in which people have
been sexist racist whatever it is
aren't i just gonna be a very
fundamentally angry person because i'm
looking for the negative in everyone
yeah i mean this is um if you look at
um if you google microaggressions on
something like twitter
a word that will often come up is
exhausted
people say that they feel exhausted by
microaggressions because they have
trained themselves into this way
of thinking and i mean an example i
i tend to give of it is is if we
were to imagine a black and a white
customer entering a shop at the same
time
and a white uh server whose job is to
go and offer them help um which one
should she approach first if she
approached the white customer first
obviously they then read this situation
as
uh white supremacy the white person came
first but if she approached the black
person first
then this situation could be read as
anti-blackness and not trusting a black
person to
peruse the shelves unsupervised so we're
always going to see
racism in everything if we're trained to
look for it
so it's ultimately self-destructive and
i don't think it can last
especially as it sort of fractures into
smaller and smaller groups
and you have um at the moment i'm
closely following
a lot of arguments between um
african-americans and recent african
immigrants
to america um and there's this
um sort of debate about privilege going
on there and then there's um the
privilege of
uh being light-skinned or dark-skinned
black person
and there's a privilege even within um
fat studies apparently um there's
people who are heavily overweight but
still have a kind of hourglass figure
have a privilege they need to
acknowledge over people who
don't have that and excellent
that sounds brilliant helen i think
there's a very british solution
to the white black custom in the shop
problem which is for the server to
ignore them both and give them no
customer service
whatsoever just grunt at them if they if
they approach yes
that that would work and
helen because what this ideology leads
to is it leads to
think people saying things there are
actually very very racist i
i saw this tweet which went viral from
this uh social justice
activist saying that straight black men
are the new straight white
males isn't it going to come to a point
where it eats itself like you said
i i have argued that it will
um combust but what i i'm i'm less
i'm less convinced now because we seem
to be
um forming more of a hierarchy so at the
top of the hierarchy are black trans
women
um obviously but we're we're losing
people we're shedding people
on on the way and you know gay men
have um sort of too too often declined
to
be social justice activists too long to
any longer be
considered marginalized and women
have been having the um
the karen trope and the white women
tears um
thing since um the votes for donald
trump so we're no longer really
considered marginalized either
i think it will narrow down it will
become an extremist
uh movement it's going to be difficult
to
um it's going to be difficult to to
to counteract but it it
it's going to have to self-destruct at
some point because it just doesn't make
any any sense it doesn't it doesn't have
an
end goal that is achievable
as we wrap up the interview we're coming
close to the end now i
i'm curious uh because you mentioned
advising people to vote for joe biden
at the top of the interview given
everything that we've
talked about why are you advocating that
people
should vote for the party that is
pushing through some of these ideas
because there are so many other ideas as
well i focus
very much on critical social justice
issues because that's what i've studied
i was
a liberal feminist and i was of the
humanities so i'm addressing this
problem because i want to fix the left
i want to make it electable again i
don't address
problems on the right um because i
i don't think there's a right way to do
conservatism i recognize
the need for conservatives i re you know
and i respect um ethical conservatives
and
their input that we need as people
they're saying
um can we conserve some of the good
stuff please do we're not don't always
have to
race ahead so you know yeah i can
respect conservatives but i'm
focused on the left because i share the
economic
positions and the social positions
of the left i no no but that part i get
but what i'm getting at is you know we
have this capital
uh the the storming of the capital which
francis and i both obviously condemned
straight away and
uh frankly there were lower trump
supporters who got upset about that but
we don't care that needed to be
condemned just like
blm violence needed to be condemned
right but
the moment it happened joe biden comes
out and makes it all about race
right so you've just advised people to
vote for somebody
i know it sounds like i'm having to go
you i'm just trying to think this out
and i'm
not having to go to you at all but you
have advised people to vote for a guy
who's literally as
his first action in in this
heated moment makes everything about
race we know
yet when if the democrats get in then we
know that the fight against critical
social justice
is going to need to become more intense
so that that's
not um i don't have any kind of belief
that
um if we vote left-wing um governments
in then all the social justice problems
will disappear they won't
they will get um emboldened however
we do now have an opportunity and what
americans do
to reject this idea that we all need to
to gather together and oppose the right
so that's what's often said to me
why are you criticizing the left when
you're on the left we should be
solidarity against the right well now
in the the democratic party has won
this is the time for the liberal lefties
for the socialists
um who uh value reason and evidence and
are not social justice activists
to to push back at this to try and
actually get their own house
in order they don't have the excuse of
fighting trumpism
anymore they need to sort their [ __ ] out
but there's one question that i actually
really wanted to ask because we talk
about privilege yet we don't talk about
a privilege that i believe
really exists and no one seems to want
to address which is beauty privilege
i am very privileged but we joke about
it
it is a real thing but we no one talks
about it you're more likely to be you're
more likely to be
more popular have more jobs offered to
you if you're hot
why don't we talk actually hot height is
a massive privilege
we're we're all revealing all our sore
spots at this point
but but yeah i mean you know what i
actually think if you made
beauty privilege that big people would
actually claim to be privileged they'd
be like yeah i'm really privileged i'm
so handsome
yeah no one's gonna say i'm ugly i'm
oppressed yeah exactly
i mean this is um when it comes to
something that
that's innate um there's often you know
there's been a lot of feminist
um objection to uh beauty privilege
because
it um is essentially sexualizing women
and and taking away
any focus on their them as people it
there's pressure to be beautiful so
there's that kind of thing but
we don't see a focus on
the kind of issues that that really are
a lottery
so um intelligence uh beauty
whether you come from a supportive and
loving family
these are really um individual and
genetic
things that that we can't do much about
socially so it's not of huge interest
um to um to to
people on the left generally and i and i
understand that to a certain extent i
think
yes we're not all going to be
supermodels or
sports stars or um you know quantum
physicists or whatever
we're going to have quite a few of us
being quite average
and we need for those people to also
have
work that isn't um soul destroying and
that they can afford to live on yeah
they can host a youtube show
helen uh i wanted to just first of all
to say from both francis and i
that we're really glad the counterweight
is now a thing
uh we will be supporting it with
everything that we've got we encourage
all our viewers to go
and check it out and to become members
of that and the free speech union
because these are two organizations that
will be critical in
in dealing with some of the problems
that we've created for ourselves
uh so thank you for coming on the show
and thank you for starting it
and before we let you go as you know uh
we have one more question for you which
is
always what is the one thing that we are
not talking about
as a society that we really should be
okay so
here's the thing and as i've pointed out
i am quite single-minded
there's um often this argument about
whether or not the implicit association
test works and whether unconscious bias
training works
and this is what it revolves around and
you know there's a lot of evidence that
it doesn't
but what gets missed with this
conversation is that
your employer doesn't actually have the
right to know what's going on in your
head in the first place
you can have whatever biases you want
what they have the right to demand is
that you behave well to your colleagues
so there needs to be more focus on the
individuals freedom of conscience and
their freedom to keep their conscience
private
absolutely and there's another question
i want to ask before we go helen
are we white and fragile you are
the two of you are i am slightly brown
and very resilient
um i'm afraid brown fragility is is also
a thing and
um oh for [ __ ] sake
[Laughter]
well excellent on that very happy note
helen tell everybody
obviously people should get cynical
theories if they haven't already
where can they uh find out more about
counterweight
okay so there's counterweightsupport.com
is the
um website which hopefully by the time
this airs will be up
and there's counterweight media on
youtube where we have a lot of short
informational
um videos and you can seek a case worker
if you need one or just
um resources by going to either of those
fantastic uh thank you so much for
coming back helen
great chatting with you and thank you
all for watching and listening
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode or a live stream
and they all go out at 7pm uk time take
care guys and see you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below